[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
rugby fait deuxième match de la saison
pour plaisir en fédérale 2 les joueurs
de sébastien roncalli l'ont emporté 35 à
0 à domicile contre poitiers avec cinq
essais à la clé le résumé du match à
suivre jo-2000 24 les drapeaux
olympiques et paralympiques ont fait
étape au bureau national de saint
quentin en yvelines ce week end une
grande cérémonie était organisée dans la
structure les détaillants ce magazine
rugby encore nous avons posé notre
caméra du côté du rugby club de
versailles nous reviendrons sur
l'histoire du rcv et ses objectifs
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
on va donc commencer par du rugby leur
dernier match à domicile remontait au 18
octobre 2020 pour leur retour au stade
robert barran le plaisir à rugby club
s'est imposé brillamment ce samedi face
à poitiers un résultat sans appel 20 35
à 0 le récit de la rencontre avec
nicolas landry ils ont gâté leur public
du stade robert barran les plaisirs oies
ont proposé une véritable démonstration
de rugby et poitiers n'a rien pu faire
pour arrêter les vagues offensives des
hommes de sébastien galy une victoire
bonifiée sur le score de 35 à 0 belle
victoire avec la manière et puis un
contenu quand même très intéressant un
gros volume de jeu donc je suis très
satisfait effectivement aujourd'hui de
la manière et puis l'état d'esprit des
joueurs quoi le coeur qu'ils ont eu une
petite déception sur quelques actions
qu'on finit pas dès le début de la
rencontre plaisir impose son rythme
vitesse mouvement continuité dans le jeu
les bleu et jaune ouvrent la marque très
rapidement au bout de 20 minutes il mène
15 à 0
puis les fautes se multiplient le match
et saccadé les sanctions tombent
jusqu'au carton rouge donné à plaisir et
poitiers après une bagarre juste avant
la mi temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en seconde période les plaisirs aux à
main tiennent la pression sur les
poitevins plus disciplinés ils
inscrivent trois essais dont un par le
capitaine françois le vilain ça fait
toujours plaisir ça faisait longtemps
que ce n'était pas arrivé mais mais
c'est pareil une belle avancée
collective de l'équipe un bon bout
demandé gros qui après resort au large
bon voilà je pense que je peux faire la
passe mais on l'aligné pas loin je vais
essayer d'aller marcher l'objectif il
est clairement affichée quoi maintenant
ça va faire la quatrième saison
consécutive que on évolue en fédérale 2
avec la première saison ça fait cinq ans
bon bah on a envie d'aller chercher une
place qualificative
les six premiers se qualifier après sa
défaite à gennevilliers lors du premier
match de la saison plaisir pointe à la
6e place
prochain match dimanche 26 septembre
face au havre
nous allons maintenant passer aux autres
résultats du week-end dans les yvelines
pour m'accompagner bixente mérian a
senti ce débat nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir bixente bon sens michael
alors chaque lundi vous allez nous
proposer un tour d'horizon des résultats
sportifs dans les villes on va tout de
suite commencer par le troisième tour de
la coupe de france de football et ça
passe tout juste avec la moyenne pour
les club yvelinois sur les 20 clubs
engagés dix accède donc au 4e tour
synonyme d'une récompense de prestige
pour les équipes les fameux maillot de
la coupe de france parmi les exploits
notable celui du voisin football club
qui l'emportent au penalty face à in y
évoluant pourtant deux divisions au
dessus en régionale 2 score final 1
partout même destin pour hardricourt le
club de régionale 3 du nord yvelines
s'est imposé contre 5 points aux tirs au
but également après un score restait
vierge à l'issue du temps réglementaire
les joies de la coupe de france qu'on a
retrouvés à plaisir également avec un
scénario d'anthologie mené 4-2 les
plaisirs a égalisé à la dernière minute
pour l'emporter au penalty également ça
nous a permis de voir une jolie scène de
communion avec les supporters on
retrouvera aussi au prochain tour le
petit poucet bréval longue pensionnaires
de la cinquième division mais aussi les
murs haut conflent chatou trappe oui et
chambourcy en revanche parmi les grosses
désillusions retiendra la défaite de
menthe oui le club de nationale 3 qui
venait pourtant d'entrée dans la
compétition a été surpris par une des
deux du 95 payne 3 parmi les autres
éliminations notables on notera
également celle de marly-le-roi nos
fleurons chartrain montils bretonneux ou
encore mort pas on passe au handball
maintenant avec une victoire pour les
filles de montilliers bretonneux en
national taux fixe sur un score large 29
à 24 face aux roses en du 29 une bonne
manière de lancer leur saison après une
défaite lors de la première journée à
plouagat elle se positionne donc à la
cinquième place du classement
côté garçons des bonnes nouvelles
également en nationale 3 plaisir les
clés s'est imposé à domicile contre
bruce 28 à 19
quant à où il le vésinet carrière sur
scène le déplacement au finistère leur a
souri avec une victoire 27-22 une
deuxième victoire en autant de matchs
pour l'entente d'une origine et la
saison de basket a enfin repris pour
trappe mais avec une première journée de
nationale 3 pour l'un des favoris du
groupe avec une victoire in extremis à
la maison 67 66 contre le mans saint
pavin pour les trappistes qui se sont
fait peur mais qui entament leur marche
en avant dans la division alors on
termine notre page résultats sur une
note plus animale oui avec la touahri
while he s ce dimanche 19 septembre une
course de 10 km au milieu des animaux
qui aura quand même vu 1500 participants
ont traversé le safari un périple donc à
travers les girafes les lions les hyènes
ou encore l'éléphant du zoo et ça allait
plutôt vite puisque le vainqueur a passé
la ligne d'arrivée en 34 minutes merci à
bixente pour toutes ces précisions vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine on va
maintenant parler à tennis le tournoi
international futur du tennis club de
plaisir s'est achevée ce dimanche 19
septembre contrat rempli pour
l'australien tristan school kate le
cette 135e joueur mondial remporte le
mais le troisième meilleur tournoi
d'ile-de-france le sportif a gagné
contre le français alexandre ricaud en
finale au reportage
c'est un australien tristane school kate
qui s'impose en finale du tournoi
international futur du tennis club de
plaisir 2021 un match remporté 6 4 7 5
en 1h35 de jeu face au français
alexandre ricaud un titre obtenu tout en
maîtrise par l'australien malgré les
difficultés du terrain j'ai beaucoup
joué sur terrain dur en extérieur en
transpirant énormément aux états unis
mais aussi sur les terres battues
d'europe c'est un très gros challenge de
jouer en salle sur du dur c'est plus
rapide j'ai dû bien servir bien retourné
je suis beaucoup monté au filet j'ai
joué beaucoup de volets je pense que
c'est ce qui m'a aidé à gagner cette
semaine la finale face au jeune français
alexandre ricaud était loin d'être
gagnée d'avancé pour l'australien le
tennisman de 22 ans était la surprise de
la semaine c'est un petit français qui
étaient dans les qualifications et qui a
traversé les qualifs qui a traversé le
tableau final et qui a perdu en finale
mais j'ai quand même une belle nageurs
de chez jeune alexandre qui a fait un
parcours merveilleux les supporters
étaient bien sûr toujours derrière lui
beaucoup d'applaudissements beaucoup de
bruit on a l'impression d'être les nuits
c'est super de gagner le match et je
suis très soulagé d'avoir remporté ce
titre comme récompense pour l'australien
de 20 ans cette 135e mondiale un chèque
de 25 mille dollars et quelques points
au classement atp qui lui permettront
peut-être d'être invités à des tournois
encore plus prestigieux on reste à
plaisir le galli athletic club et sa
section locale du plaisir athletic club
ont organisé avec la ville un meeting
d'athlétisme une première depuis un
mille neuf cents à 97 des dizaines
d'athlètes ont répondu présents pour ce
rendez vous des images de mélanie poké
ils sont allés au bout d'eux-mêmes ce
samedi 18 septembre 90 athlètes ont
souffert sur la piste du stade bernard
giroux de plaisir à l'occasion du
meeting d'athlétisme ghani à ses
plaisirs l'événement était organisé par
le club local une grande première depuis
1997 ça commence à faire long conseiller
pour redynamiser un petit peu à cette
histoire yves binois et locales on
voulait
réellement donné hier un nouvel élan en
organisant un meeting en septembre au
programme ce jour là un 200 m 1 400 m et
1500 m 1 5000 m le planning a été défini
à la dernière minute pour ce meeting
deux reprises déjà appelé chaque
entraîneur pour leur demander quelles
dates en arrière où allons-nous choisir
et quelle épreuve alors nous choisir en
fonction du calendrier de chacun de base
ce qu'il a été rajoutée sur le
calendrier initialement prévu et ils ont
choisi en fonction des tas physique de
chacun plusieurs clubs locaux et
normands ont participé à l'événement
franchement la piste unique ait rien à
redire les conditions météo était
parfaite
quand ses instincts un bon meeting on
est content d'être là parce que
normalement on devait faire un meeting à
cergy pontoise qui a été annulé quand on
est très content de venir à plaisir
d'avoir un plan de secours que j'allais
même pas qu'ils avaient un ultime ici
c'est super un nouveau meeting devrait
être organisée cet été par le club
l'objectif sera d'attirer encore plus de
participants avec un programme plus
large
les jeux de tokyo à peine refermées que
tous les regards sont désormais braqués
à dans trois ans en 2024 paris
accueillera la 33e olympiade de l'ère
moderne à une grande fête qui démarre
déjà avec de nombreux événements jusqu'à
l'échéance mondiale samedi à 18h
septembre le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillez le
passage des drapeaux aux olympiques pour
nous parler de ces drapeaux nous
recevons sur ce plateau gregory canal et
journaliste chez tv 78 bonsoir mon sur
michael alors cette journée était
l'occasion pour le public de rencontrer
les athlètes tricolores et paris 2024 ce
n'est que dans trois ans et pourtant
l'engouement était déjà bien présent
regardez ces images le public était là
samedi pour accueillir cet événement
athlètes élus ont déambulé sur la piste
du vélodrome nationale dans leurs mains
les drapeaux et comités olympiques et
paralympiques remis par la ville de
tokyo à la maire de paris anne hidalgo
lors des cérémonies de clôture mais
aussi le drapeau de paris 2024 pour
mener le cortège notamment vous le voyez
thierry rey conseiller spécial de paris
2024 et surtout champion olympique de
judo à moscou en 1980 pour lui le compte
à rebours a bel et bien démarré ça veut
vraiment dire que ça y est on y est on
est pays on est le pays de l'olympisme
du paralympiques mme on a attendu
longtemps on a même attendu un an de
plus à cause de la qu'ovide est donc
enfin tokyo a remis le drapeau à la
merde et paris et on est dans notre
lympia des il est important aussi que
ces drapeaux et voyages il reste pas
seulement à paris ils aillent sur les
territoires est aujourd'hui souvent un
site olympique en 51 yvelines au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
en plus du vélodrome nationale qui
accueillera le cyclisme sur piste et le
bmx mitchell il ya le golf national à
lui en cours il ya aussi la colline à
elancourt pour le vtt comme sites
olympiques on est donc forcément
impatient à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
côté élus et côté habitants c'est génial
de dire qu'on est en train de
représenter les sources à la fixer ces
importants quoique c'est trop bien c'est
que rien de ce soit en point on a la
passion on attend et on sera derrière
l'équipe de prost la force portante
qu'est-ce que de plus beau que de
réveiller l'envi de donner envie à
quelqu'un de se dépasser si le top c'est
une fois en plus tous les siècles on
peut la voir on est très fiers choix
pour saint quentin
d'y être associés aussi directement
cette cérémonie du drapeau était le
moment aussi de croiser à les sportifs
qui rêvent de paris 2024 lui visera l'or
dans trois ans à paris le pisteur du
vaisseau skyteam vous sert florian
gringo 21 ans est revenu de tokyo avec
une médaille de bronze glanée en vitesse
par équipes après des jeux cadenassé par
la crise sanitaire c'était l'occasion
pour l'hybride mois de fêter cette
médaille olympique avec le public sur
tokyo on n'avait pas forcément le public
eh ben ça montre qu'on est soutenu et
c'est juste fou et je me dire depuis le
retour en france c'est là qu'on se rend
compte vraiment ce que sont les jeux
olympiques et on se rend compte que
c'est quelque chose qui touche tout le
monde qui touche vraiment tout tout pays
donc vraiment content vraiment fier
pouvoir partager tout ça tous sont en
tête désormais l'échéance des jeux de
paris 2024 qui se dérouleront en plus à
la maison et pour les pistards de
l'équipe de france dans l'écrin du
vélodrome nationale qu'ils connaissent
bien plus de pression sans doute mais
aussi une motivation supplémentaire pour
être de la partie l'heure est au travail
on le connaît bien puisque ça fait déjà
quelques années qu'on est là et
et on va continuer de bien en profiter
ça nous donne un bel avantage aussi
puisque c'est une piste qu'on connaît
par coeur après voilà il reste et non il
reste quand même du temps même si on a
l'impression que c'est demain et ce
temps là on va essayer de le passer à
travailler correctement je trouve que
c'est génial de pouvoir être contact
avec beaucoup de monde et personne qui
nous encouragent au fur et à mesure
c'est motivant pour la suite c'est vrai
que c'est à la maison c'est ici à bourg
de saint quentin en yvelines donc dans
trois ans le compte à rebours il est
déjà lancé et c'est juste
c'est un sentiment qui ne serait pas
comment le décrire parce que je sens que
ça va être énorme ça va être fort et
qu'il va falloir être présent je pense
que c'est une chance pour tous les
français d'avoir les jeux en 2024 mais
tout le monde est content en français et
en 2024 il y aura aussi les jeux
paralympiques bien sûr à paris on espère
y voir cécile sabouraud l apparat
triathlète était l'une des têtes
d'affiché de la cérémonie d'être à pau
est sélectionné pour tokyo 2020 l'élan
courtoise avait dû renoncer après un
grave accident de vélo pendant sa
préparation j'ai pas beaucoup de monde
ces derniers temps il m'arrivait de mes
aventures j'ai eu un accident 30 jours
avant les jeux j'ai eu dix fracture 5,2
cote 4 deux vertèbres une du crâne voilà
je me suis retrouvé seul suis très déçu
là j'ai quand même le contrecoup de pas
être jeu et puis là de voir du monde
ouais ça fait du bien c'est chaleureux
on lui souhaite bien sûr bon courage
dans dix jours elle va reprendre
progressivement le sport avec un
objectif en tête être à paris à 2024
quant au drapeau michael ils vont
continuer leur tournée dans une
trentaine de villes en france
prochaine étape dans les ebooks ce sera
le 16 octobre à elancourt merci à
grégory on aura l'occasion de vous
retrouver tous les mois pour votre
rubrique sur les jeux olympiques de 2024
avec un désir alors on va maintenant
prendre la direction de versailles
chaque semaine tv 70 2 vous propose un
focus ion un club adhésives il
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur le
rcv le rugby-club de versailles à
regarder
[Musique]
nous sommes sur les terrains du stade de
porchefontaine aujourd'hui coup de
projecteur sur le rugby club de
versailles c'est parti
[Musique]
le rugby-club de versailles a été fondé
en
1893 pierre chevalier le responsable
communication du club est avec nous il
va nous parler de
l'histoire du club d'histoire et
versailles est une ville d'histoire et
de culture elle est devenue au fur et à
mesure en à la fin du 19e siècle une
ville de culture sportive et donc
effectivement les premiers les premières
passes de rugby dans la cour du lycée
hoche donc ça c'est pas tout jeune donc
fin du 19e siècle sa 19e et versailles
est un des dix plus vieux club de rugby
de france le septième si si on doit y
est exact mais pourquoi ça après à
versailles justement plus qu'ailleurs
peut-être peut-être justement cette
cette culture cette culture et cette
culture physique la cour du lycée hoche
avec avec les premières les peut-être
les premières bribes de la culture
britannique où est né le rugby est avec
justement 7,7 export du rugby
d'angleterre en france et peut-être au
plus près de paris et des villes
culturels sportifs et sportives autour
de paris du coup ça a pas mal bougé à à
versailles ça n'a pas forcément été tout
le temps ici à penchot fontaine à quel
moment ça c'est localisé ici sur le
terrain de de porchefontaine part
effectivement d'une cour d'école et au
fur et à mesure on va dire que dans les
années 50 60
le rugby se stabilise dans les environs
porchefontaine évidemment pas sur ses
installations là et pas tel quel mais
elle est passée aussi autour de montbron
et des différentes enceintes sportives
de la ville de versailles vous avez une
idée ou pas du nombre de joueurs qui
sont passés sur sur ces terrains là il
faudrait qu'on fasse le calcul mais
depuis depuis effectivement son trente
et quelques années ça en fait beaucoup
parce que versailles est un est un club
formateur donc on y vient à tout âge on
est formé au rugby de l'école de rugby
jusqu'en jusqu'en seniors et même
jusqu'en vétérans avec l'équipe des
vieux crampons alors sur le terrain est
ce que versailles brille alors
versailles a toujours été un club
bien implanté en termes de régions
régionalement et au niveau national et
fédérales meilleur niveau atteint par
par le club en seniors c'est celui qu'il
occupe actuellement en fédérale 3 et
après viser plus haut c'est une histoire
d'ambition dont on parlera plus tard
[Musique]
nous sommes maintenant avec le maire de
versailles françois de mazières françois
de mazières qu'est ce que ça représente
pour vous le rugby-club de versailles
avec le rugby club de versailles c'est
essentiel à la ville de versailles de
bord c'est un club c'est le plus ancien
de la ville de versailles c'est un club
exceptionnel qui a des beaux résultats
qui vit vous pouvez voir dans un cadre
magnifique et puis maintenant qui est
animé par une équipe extrêmement aux
dynamiques et avec des personnes qui
vraiment ont pris en charge comme moi
c'est un très beau club est très fier de
lui et comment la ville justement
soutien peut-être qu'on l'a on voit les
infrastructures là juste derrière
comment comment la ville aide en fait
finalement le rugby-club de versailles
alors vous avez raison le dire la ville
est d'abord les clubs sportifs pour les
installations les installations à ville
de versailles sont assez exceptionnelles
on bénéficie d'un cadre qui est un cadre
vais au bucolique vous pouvez voir ça
c'est très rare et je sais que les gens
qui viennent ici sont toujours contents
le découvrir c'est le premier atout le
deuxième à tous évidemment des
subventions elles ne sont pas
considérables parce que la ville de
versailles contrairement à l'image
qu'elle doit c'est une ville plutôt
pauvre puisqu'il n'y a pas d'activité
économique donc un mode très fort il est
significatif notamment dans les
investissements d'où vient il ya
quelques années
faire un investissement important sur
les vestiaires du club sont très beaux
et il ya beaucoup de monde aussi un qui
vient pour encourager l'équipe de
versailles notamment le dimanche ici ça
arrive qui est 300 400 personnes des
fois autour du terrain absolument il ya
un esprit c'est le rugby aussi c'est un
esprit sain esprit je vais pas parler à
troisième mi temps mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya un peu de ça aussi ils sont très
solidaires et ça fait partie je disais
tout à l'heure un de l'histoire de cette
ville de versailles c'est un club qui
est vraiment ancré dans la ville on y
passe génération génération souvent et
ça fait partie vraiment aussi de la
formation et du quatier parce que ça
c'est un point sur lequel il faut
insister c'est que tous les responsables
de ce club sont conscients qu'ils
forment aussi les jeunes qui sont ici
dans le club merci pour soi nazir merci
à vous merci
[Musique]
l'échauffement vient tout juste de
débuter ici assure le stade de
porchefontaine à mes côtés éric tournier
le président alors est-ce que tout est
en place quand on voit un échauffement
comme celui là bas ça ça commence là
puisque depuis le mois de juin il
s'entraîne donc on était impatients et
on est impatient effectivement ce tous
les joueurs de débuter ce championnat
qui je l'espère va durer au moins
jusqu'au mois de juin donc là il
s'entraîne deux mois je pense que on est
on est bien parti pour ce premier match
donc là on voit l'équipe une de cet
effectif comment vous trouvez cet
effectif quand vous l'avez façonné sur
cette nouvelle saison là on a eu du
temps du coup à cause de la saison
dernière donc on a bien mon ami du temps
on a identifié les joueurs dans d'autres
clubs
ce qu'il manquait on a eu très peu de
turnover donc on a bien ciblé huit
nouveaux joueurs qui vont je l'espère
nous permettre d'accéder à la fédérale 2
mais comment on imagine un mercato quand
on est président de versailles justement
est-ce qu'on réfléchisse à l'adn du club
qui est plutôt familiale où est ce qu'on
va chercher peut-être des pépites un peu
venu de l'extérieur ça se passe comment
tout simplement dire que c'est un mixte
le premier critère serre est un club
familial donc on va chercher des
personnalités souvent on va les chercher
à travers le réseau des joueurs
on a suivi pendant un an deux ans on se
rapproche de on leur présente notre
projet et où il a deja si rapidement et
du coup ça nous permet effectivement de
pouvoir est au fait on avait terminé au
mois d'avril notre recrutement du coup
cette saison vous l'avez dit objectif
fédérale 2 c'est vraiment l'objectif du
club de pérenniser club au plus haut
niveau finalement c'est plus qu'un
objectif c'est j'ai bien insisté
dès le début oui c'est notre petit ce
principe aller au delà on va aller c'est
d'aller chercher un peu rond chanter la
france
plusieurs tours mais quand on fait pour
structurer un club comme versailles on
l'a dit c'est un club historique
la municipalité vous aide on l'a vu
justement a précédemment avec le maire
de la commune qui vous soutient est ce
que il faut chercher les partenaires
peut-être pour faire grossir encore plus
ce club c'est indispensable on a
effectivement le soutien de la
municipalité mais au-delà de ça on a le
soutien des licenciés puisque on a quand
même plus de 600 licenciés donc ça nous
permet effectivement d'avoir une aide
financière est bien évidemment les
partenaires 60 partenaires privés qui
nous ont suivis qu'ils ont soutenu même
pendant la période du coc vide qui nous
accompagnent la depuis maintenant
plusieurs années on a en en perspective
d'autres partenaires de plus en plus
important ces jeunes joueurs qui
évoluent à versailles ont eu 12 ans u14
est-ce qu'ils sont voués à venir jouer
ici a juste derrière nous sur cette
pelouse évidemment et d'ailleurs on a
cette année investi beaucoup sur dès le
plus jeune âge des derozan sur des
centres de perfectionnement donc on
attache beaucoup d'importance à notre
formation c'est notre adn afin de
pouvoir les amener le plus haut possible
vers notre objectif qui est la fédérale
2 donc oui on a intégré même dès cette
année dans le groupe senior encore trois
nouveaux
juniors qui vont passer un enseignant à
terme peut-être l'idée ce serait d'avoir
une équipe 100% versaillaise issus du
centre de formation
ce serait l'idéal maintenant on sait
très bien qu'on aura toujours des
manques sur certains postes donc si on
arrive à 80% l'équipe première de
versailles et ce serait ça serait
extraordinaire
le président éric tournier a parlé de
fédérale 2 dans les prochaines années
ici à versailles nous allons demander au
coach typhaine pour savoir ce qu'ils en
pensent alors typhaine qu'est ce que
vous en pensez tout simplement de cette
fédérale 2 dans les prochaines années
ici à versailles il s'avoue motivé
j'imagine écoutez haut et ça motive
c'est un peu l'objectif que le club
s'est donné au travers de nouer de
l'effectif bien évidemment comme tout le
temps on consulte bas nos joueurs ont
consulté un petit peu le groupe pour
savoir un petit peu où ils veulent aller
comment ils se sentent et quels sont les
objectifs qu'on pourrait mettre sur le
moyen et long terme et phyto
effectivement le club souhaite rejoindre
l'année prochaine la fédérale 2 qui vous
le savez va changer puisque les il va
avoir une refonder des catégories et là
l'année prochaine la division ça se
rappellera division 2 au lieu de
fédérale 2 voilà donc c'est l'objectif
de cette saison je pose également la
question antoine désolé je veux mais
entre vous deux vous étiez en plein
exercice antoine a alors tout simplement
la fédérale 2 est ce que c'est possible
avec cet effectif vous faites partie des
anciens du club et aurait des anciens
tout à fait pas la fédérale 2 c'est tout
nouveau pour pour moi qui suis un ancien
ça jamais été un objectif du club on a
connu la fédérale 3 la descente en
honneur la remontée donc ouais ouais
c'est un super super objectif je pense
que le club le les coaches les le
président toute l'équipe tout bureau on
fait vraiment le boulot pour recruter
des super joueurs donc ouais ouais bien
sûr qu'on y croit tous ont commencé une
saison sans y croire c'est ça n'existe
pas donc ouais on y croit dur si on a
fait des belles saisons les deux années
précédentes on s'était coupé par le cos
vie c'est pour tout le monde pareil mais
ouais on a appelé en a envie quand
ambitieux mais je pense qu'on a
l'effectif pour aller jusqu'au bout de
nos ambitions et ça se traduit comment à
l'entraînement on voit tous les hyper
motivés en ce début de saison web a
beaucoup de sérieux c'est sûr bah les
places seront chères parce que comme je
vous le dis et beaucoup de recrutements
donc beaucoup de joueurs pour chaque
poste donc qu il va falloir se battre
pour ses places et se battre pour sa
place certains soucis parfum en tout
premier lieu par effectivement être
sérieux et assidu à l'entraînement donc
beaucoup de concentration mais c'est
bien mais est-ce que coach typhaine est
ravie de l'effectif bah oui forcément
puisque c'est moi qui l'ait voulu donc
je vais pas dire il vaut mieux et voilà
il vaut mieux donc aujourd'hui comme
vous savez on a on a et à bien un plan
d'action sur justement les éléments qui
nous manquait pour réaliser justement
cet objectif ça fait trois ans
maintenant qu'on travaille très
sérieusement heureusement avec le avec
le club comme vous savez on a une
philosophie ici à versailles d'être sur
la formation et sur nos jeunes donc la
priorité est quand même aussi d'intégrer
un maximum de jeunes sur notre équipe
seniors et sur l'équipe première on a
encore la chance cette année d'avoir une
belle génération de juniors qui va
monter avec des joueurs qui vont
intégrer directement le groupe le groupe
une avec des jeunes joueurs de 18 ans
très prometteur et qui vont pouvoir
justement grâce à sa faire passer un cap
plus la venue des joueurs extérieurs
voilà sur des postes bien cibler un
jamais un recrutement fait comme ça à la
va vite c'est vraiment fait sur sur des
postes sur des choses qui nous manquait
pour justement atteindre nos objectifs
donc oui effectivement nous on est très
content du recrutement et en plus pour à
repasser un petit peu de mots et de
temps avec eux là je peux vous dire que
c'est vraiment plus des supers mecs
humainement donc c'est magnifique et ici
à verser aussi la philosophie c'est de
jouer de proposer du jeu également pour
pour le public on sait qu'il ya
énormément de supporters qui viennent
chaque week-end pour pour vous soutenir
est ce que c'est important de leur faire
plaisir aussi peut-être ben je crois que
de toute façon le but aujourd'hui c'est
le sport amateur on est là pour s'amuser
on est là pour prendre du plaisir
aujourd'hui nous ce qui nous anime c'est
c'est que tout le monde vienne avec
beaucoup d'entrain et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le fait de proposer un
jeu de mouvement et un jeu d'évitement
bah c'est quelque chose qui nous plaît à
tous donc aujourd'hui on
essaie d'exceller de dents voilà des
fois on n'y arrive pas et des fois ça
fonctionne mais en tout cas on y met
plein de coeur pour qui on puisse
réaliser justement ce fameux de jeu à la
versaillaise antoine le jeu à la
versaillaise ça sera encore pour cette
année le cubain le le collectif ultra
versailles est présent à chaque
rencontre il met beaucoup d'ambiance
faut leur faire plaisir ah bah ça c'est
sûr que l'on a vu des années passent et
le soutien qu'ils nous ont apporté ces
c'est vraiment essentiel il met une
sacrée ambiance donc pour reprendre un
peu ce qu'ils étaient fin évidemment
leur faire plaisir nous faire plaisir et
que leur faire plaisir c'est vraiment
l'objectif on compte sur eux vraiment
très très fort sur cette saison parce
que voilà vue les objectifs l'effectif
est ce qu'on essaie de mettre en place
avec les coachs il y aura sûrement du
beau spectacle en tout cas on l'espère
et et s'ils le peuvent mettre l'ambiance
en tribune c
[Musique]
un club historique avec énormément
dormition dont une montée en fédérale 2
l'année prochaine et tout cela avec des
jeunes du club si vous voulez suivre
laventure dé versailles et rendez vous
ce dimanche 26 septembre à houilles
on continue à parler rugby un autre
match à ne pas manquer à ce week-end le
club de maisons laffitte saint germain
poissy se rendra ce dimanche sur le
terrain de cergy pontoise à l'occasion
de la première journée du championnat de
fédérale 3 le mlsgp fait partie des plus
grosses équipes de cette division espère
remporter une première victoire pour
cette rentrée la rencontre se déroulera
au stade jean loustau à pontoise enfin
on termine par deux à la voile la
conférence de presse de la 15e édition
de la transat jacques vabre est
programmée ce jeudi à paris louis burton
originaire de rambouillet sera présent
sur la ligne de départ de cette course
en double sans escale et sans assistance
il partira avec son ami à davy beaudart
le 7 novembre prochain pour aller en
direction du brésil le duo a réussi la
semaine dernière à prendre la quatrième
place sur le défi azimuts avec leur
bateau à bure vallée de bonne augure
pour novembre prochain c'est la fin de
cette émission à merci de l'avoir suivi
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]